on constate encore une fois depuis
quelques jours les réseaux sociaux
peuvent passé maître dans l'art de
ridiculiser une personne c'est ce qui
est arrivé dans le cas de l'étudiante
naomi tremblay trudeau atteinte par un
projectile lors d'une manifestation et
dont la blessure a fait l'objet d'une
page facebook qui se moquer de sa
blessure discute avec matthieu dugal
avant son match d'abord cette page
facebook elle existe encore après une
série de valse hésitation elle était
finalement fermé mais il reste pas moins
que c'est emblématique d'une certaine
culture d'internet qu'on appelle le
troll et quand on parle de 3 mais le
troll en fait c'est un ça fait partie du
folklore du web depuis les années 90 sur
les fameux forum c'est la métaphore dont
du verbe tout rôle de qui de laisser
traîner une ligne à pêche et de prendre
les poissons qui passe autour alors
qu'est ce que ça fait un troll sur les
réseaux sociaux mais ça ça fait déraper
des conversations par des commentaires
agressifs dans les commentaires extrême
est-ce qu'on peut aller jusqu'à parler
de déviation mentale parce que c'est
extrêmement dur parfois empreinte très
méchant effectivement on en discute et
récemment à l'émission à la sphère avec
une hauteur à hélices des audi qui
travaille là dessus qu'ils rapportaient
une étude de l'université du matin du
manitoba s'est intéressée donc à 1200
personnes dont des gens qui commandent
sur les réseaux sociaux et on
s'intéressait à une chose qu'on appelle
coutelier ça la tetra de noir de la
personnalité noire alors qu'est ce que
ça regroupe cela regroupe des caractères
comme le narcissisme le machiavélisme la
psychopathie et le sadisme et on ne
trouvait parmi les jeunes hommes souvent
qui commentait sur les réseaux sociaux
mais ont coché dans tout toutes ces
choses là donc c'est un genre de sadisme
ordinaire sur les réseaux sociaux on
prédisait comme ça charmant comme ça se
retrouve où donc c'est trop les fils de
commentaires beaucoup en sollicitons le
cicr ici radio canada.ca ça se retrouve
aussi sur des sites comme forte jeunes
qui sont des soucis sur internet sont
extrêmement populaire chez les jeunes et
où on fait l'apologie met vraiment en
riant le du meurtre du racisme du
sexisme et il ya même des soucis de
fortune passée des gens qui ont été
bannis de ce et qui maintenant se sont
regroupées sur un autre vocable et chan
donc des gens trop extrême pour les
experts - est-ce qu'on peut être traîné
en cour pour ce genre de propos là ça
arrive rarement c'est arrivé deux jours
en angleterre et il
quatre ans au québec on se souvient de
jeff saibene a été reconnu coupable
d'harcèlement après avoir proféré des
menaces contre des personnalités dont
michel blanc donc guy a lepage mais dans
le cas de naomi trembler le trou d'eau
ça n'allait pas jusque là quand même
quand même on n'était pas loin parce
qu'il faut pas oublier qu'on a on s'est
moqué des on le compare une actrice
pornographique ont fait c'est d'aider
des blagues caractère hautement sexistes
et ce qu'on voit dans cette affaire là
est ce qui est peut-être plus
préoccupant c'est qu'on voit en fait
l'émergence d'un discours qui était dans
une sous culture du web mais qui
émergent dans un discours public et qui
souvent légitimes et on le voit on le
vus par des radios d'opinion qui
trouvent ça elle très drôle de voir
qu'on comprend rien personne comme ça
alors pendant qu'on fait ça c'est comme
les trolls sur les forums de discussion
sur les listes mais pendant qu'on parle
de son on parle pas d'autres enjeux
alors est-ce qu'on pourrait se dire que
dans ce cas précis le les trolls ont
gagné la question se pose
malheureusement mais il est tout à
fléaux merci beaucoup monsieur nous
désire parler